can you imagine being on a call with get
this elton john dua lipa little nazak
stevie nicks and even more stars well
the rocket man himself was joined by the
most of the collaborators who appeared
on his latest album the lockdown
sessions for what could possibly be the
most star-studded zoom call of all time
take a look we'll be back here tomorrow
guys we love you
next time
thank you
let's see who's here
hey elsie hey
everybody
wow lovely to see so many beautiful
faces hello uncle elton
hi
how's everyone doing miley
juarez nikki you look so lovely you know
it takes a small army hey y'all what's
up hey everybody i can't believe
everyone's here
wait
why is there a cat
how random why a cat
who's the cat is that you ollie guys
it's me is is ollie underneath can you
tell oh cute
olly i think i prefer you as the cat if
there's anything that's going to make a
difference in the world
uh
connected with love
is music you know
and uh we do it from our hearts we do it
from our experiences
um
and we share those emotions with you the
people stevie i love you so much thanks
for doing the song with me it's one of
my favorite things ever congratulations
on your album thank you for having me be
a part of it naz are you ever not on the
move
i love that about you i know you're very
busy and you need to go soon but i just
want to thank you from the bottom of my
heart for your time
and for working with me on this album
it's really been a dream come true thank
you
so much thank you elton love you
i miss it
it's supposed to be on zoom
and now you're here but now you're here
i suppose i could squeeze you in
as is my wand come on let's let's just
merry christmas everyone merry christmas